welcome to the stream this is going to
be the last stream for a while because I
am heading to Washington DC for some
very interesting meetings a little bit
later this week and I probably just
won't have time to stream again so this
is this is it at least for a few days
I'm going to give a second for people to
get connected want to talk about the
latest very very strange pronouncements
about complicated Airlines from the
President of the United States people
are very interested in seeing the video
so our podcast from today's show went
live but the clip of producer Noah
Ferguson confronting Shirley
phelps-roper from the Westboro Baptist
Church at a protest hasn't gone live on
YouTube so a lot of people have heard
the audio haven't seen the video I will
play the video for you because I have it
here and available so we will do that
and I predict a good turnout today i big
news as i'm doing the doing the
livestream today for the first time with
my new contact lenses I just got my
eyesight got even worse and I have new
contact lenses and I can see so much
better I can see everything that's going
on I will better be able to see if
people are trolling the live chat and
all of that stuff so it's very very
exciting and glad you're here on a on a
special day on which I can now see again
after two years of deteriorating
eyesight this is a live stream so if
this is your first one unlike the video
clips that we upload this is live and
you can talk to me you can send in
questions or comments which I will
answer or respond to by using the super
chat function that's the dollar sign
below the chat dollar sign the messages
will go up on screen I will read your
question or comment and then answer it
people get very excited sometimes with
some people pay to troll me with super
chat but for the most part it's good
questions and comments sign up for
membership I am willing to take live
calls as I often do I usually say if we
get 10 new
embers on our website I'll open up the
phone lines at six one seven eight three
zero forty seven fifty and then people
can talk to me and I will actually take
live phone calls how to sign up for
membership
ww join pakman.com coupon codes are
available check the video description
I'll talk about them a little bit more
later please don't troll the live chat
we do have moderators observing what's
going on there and we are running a not
a tight ship but a moderately tight ship
obvious trolling will get you banned
subtle trolling probably won't because
we won't notice and then lastly we are
participating in a youtube beta program
called YouTube channel membership which
displays the join button right below the
video window you can do that and we will
count those towards the goal of 10 new
members on the opening up the phone
lines questions so both website
memberships as well as YouTube channel
memberships all counts and I look
forward to hearing from people once we
get the phone lines opened so let's get
right to it
I interviewed today dr. John Gartner dr.
John Gartner has been on the program
before this interview is already up on
the YouTube channel I encourage you to
check it out after the stream dr. John
Gartner's a psychiatrist he's been
teaching for nearly 30 years at Johns
Hopkins Medical Center Medical School
and his argument is that it is very
clearly observable based on publicly
available audio-visual evidence that
Donald Trump is suffering from some
combination of cognitive decline pre
dementia mental illness and he believes
that it is the the question of dyslexia
we actually discussed the question of
could this just be dyslexia what we are
observing from Donald Trump and dr. John
Gartner said absolutely not okay so
check out the interview with him and
very interestingly every time see if we
can actually pull up some of the
comments we always address this issue of
whether it's okay to not diagnose but at
least consider hypothesize about
someone's condition on the basis of
a television or radio without having
personally examined them and this dates
back to the Goldwater rule and we
actually discussed that with John
Gartner and he says that was that was
for a very specific reason to avoid
irresponsible diagnosis without actually
sitting with someone but that it's it's
perfectly reasonable for mental health
professionals to observe someone's
public behavior and no matter what I
always see comments about that let's see
if there are any so far most people seem
to agree with this actually surprising
for now not many people are saying that
it's irresponsible for doctor John
Gardner to say this it seems that
comments like this are more common thank
you for stating the obvious that's why
it Trump's perfect for the Republican
Party Trump is all of the above everyone
should remind him he deserves it he's
someone with an Ivy League education
although Cohen's testimony suggests it
might have been from privilege rather
than merit
okay so interestingly we're not getting
a lot of those comments today last time
we had John Gardner on we did get a lot
of those comments so check that out so
the context is that if you look at
Trump's videos from the 80s and 90s his
behavior is vocabulary his demeanor is
just drastically different and this
particular psychiatrist attributes it to
cognitive decline pre dementia mental
illness just after we did this interview
today Donald Trump attacking modern
airplane technology in a very strange
series of tweets this is of course
related to this horrible horrible crash
of a Boeing 737 max operated by
Ethiopian Airlines over the weekend the
second 737 max crash that took place
shortly after takeoff in the last five
or six months most countries have
grounded 737 maxes and don't allow them
in their airspace the US has not yet
done that but it may well be coming
Donald Trump tweeting airplanes are
becoming far too complex to fly pilots
are no longer needed but rather computer
scientists from MIT I see it all the
time in many products always seeking to
go one
necessary step further when often old
and simpler is far better split-second
decisions are needed and the complexity
creates danger all of this for great
cost yet very little gain I don't know
about you but I don't want Albert
Einstein to be my pilot I want great
flying professionals that are allowed to
easily and quickly take control of a
plane this is obviously it's wrong okay
obviously if you just google flight
safety data safety per passenger mile
flown or whatever metric you want to
look at modern commercial aviation is
safer than ever ever okay today right
now it's safer than ever so Donald Trump
is wrong but it's also irresponsible
it's irresponsible because of how it's
going to affect American businesses
potentially it's irresponsible because
of the reality that a lot of people have
significant anxiety around flying and
that seeing something like this from the
president is undoubtedly going to make a
lot of those people even more anxious
and it's irresponsible because we want
the president setting the tone and
setting the agenda in a way that
actually correlates is proportional to
the problems that we're dealing with so
along those lines commercial aviation is
extraordinarily safe we don't need the
president saying things like this on the
other hand the climate change issue is a
fiasco I mean it's an absolute disaster
and Donald Trump is now insisting that
it's it's just all fake right and it's
going beyond his idea that China
concocted global warming or climate
change as a pretext to bolster their
manufacturing industry that was years
ago he's again just insisting that the
data is all fake everything's fake he
should be talking about climate change
as a real and present danger he should
not be talking about commercial aviation
there's something going on with the
Boeing 737 max clearly Boeing has an
urgent has urgency to deal with it
Trump doesn't need to get involved we
have the FAA we have the NTSB we have
all sorts of authorities and smart
people who are who are going to do
everything they can to figure out what
is wrong with the 737 max soon
possible irresponsible completely and
totally counterproductive I want to
follow up on this tomorrow we will we
will actually probably delve into some
of the specifics of what is hypothesized
to be going on with the 737 max tomorrow
and I look forward to doing that with
you but I don't know that it's necessary
to say too much more today about it let
me deal with a couple of Super chats
that have come in and then I want to get
to the Westboro Baptist Church thing
that we've been talking about let's see
here I think the first one was JC Pocket
who sent a dollar super chat starting us
off with no question or comment but I
still appreciated JC Dana Cooley Keith
sent a dollar 99 super chat also with no
question or comment very much
appreciated Trevor Peterson says with a
four dollar and twenty cent super chat
are you coming to Milwaukee for the DNC
we have great beer I don't know yet I
would love to go I would love to go you
know the thing about the DNC and the RNC
is that you there's no reason you would
know this unless you've dealt with it
but the logistics are just hell for
broadcasting from places like the DNC in
the RNC the security situation makes it
such that you need to a lot some
ludicrous amount of time even to get
into the facility they are often there
are often all sorts of different
gatekeepers put in place to get you the
resources that you need in terms of
internet connections and even just like
a table and a power strip or whatever
could bring the power strip of course
but the logistics barriers that are put
in place are often complex and what we
often end up deciding is that we can do
better content by having two or three
people who will be at the DNC call in or
Skype into the show each day rather than
me going although I would be interested
in going I've never have I been to
Milwaukee no I've never been to
Milwaukee I've been to the outskirts of
Milwaukee but never Milwaukee itself I
would love to go but it's more of a
question of whether we can do the best
possible show there
and sometimes we can't sometimes we
can't and that's ultimately what what is
going to determine what we do the reason
why with a 10 dollar super chat says
good luck on your trip Dave yeah it's uh
hopefully I don't need luck but it's
going to be interesting some very
interesting stuff going on in DC later
this week that I'll be doing and I
should be able to fill you in on it
probably next week unless unless things
are embargoed as they say Thomas Scott
Maury sends a five Australian dollar
super chat do you agree with Pelosi that
impeachment of Trump would likely be
counterproductive I here's my view on
the impeachment issue a productive and
counterproductive would not be the
terminology that I apply to it
if Donald if there's evidence that
Donald Trump has engaged in behavior
worthy of impeachment on the basis of of
the law and the Constitution and how
impeachment guidelines are outlined then
the right process is for the House of
Representatives to file impeachment
proceedings and start them it will then
be up to a republican-controlled Senate
at least up until January of 2021 to
decide on the removal of President Trump
and I think it's very unlikely that they
would vote to remove him so for me the
question is not is it productive or
unproductive to consider impeaching the
president if it's the right thing the
process should be started it's more the
pragmatic reality that we're only 20 20
months under 20 months out we are like
19 and a half months out from the 2020
election and I believe that at this
point in time if impeachment proceedings
were to start today and maybe even if
25th amendment removal procedures were
to start today although that's less
clear they're less likely but maybe
faster I still believe the most direct
path the removing Donald Trump is just
voting him out in November of 2020 you
don't have to get beyond partisan Senate
you don't have to do anything that we
don't do every four years you could just
go out and vote and we can make the
decision to remove him in 19 and a half
months and then he would actually be
removed in 21 and a half months I
believe it is so I I disagree with Nancy
Pelosi about how she's making the
calculus
I don't think productive versus
unproductive is the way to consider it
if the if impeachment is appropriate
impeachment should be done with no
regard to the sort of productivity of it
whatever that means pragmatically
speaking we can vote him out in 19 and a
half months and and that's sort of the
way that I would suggest we go about it
okay let me say hello to a couple of
people who have become members as I
mentioned at the top of the stream we do
have a phone line six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty if you call
that line now it will go to voicemail
why because I've not opened the phone
lines
why because I will open the phone lines
if and when we get ten new paid
subscribers to the show during the
stream that's just one and a half
percent of the the people that are
watching right now okay so it should be
doable you can go to WWE and Comm there
are two coupon codes available right now
the first coupon code is this is 2020
this is two zero to zero any membership
will be discounted by 40% if you apply
the code this is twenty twenty three
dollars and sixty cents a month would be
your net price for the $6 a month
membership if however you really want to
get a yearly membership and lock in a
very very it's an embarrassingly low
price quite frankly the coupon code
saved thirty five SAV e35 can be applied
only to the $60 a year membership and
that will drop the membership to
twenty-five bucks for the entire year
that's barely to two dollars a month
just over two dollars a month it
supports all the work we do it supports
the live streams and the broadcast show
and the podcast and the YouTube channel
and everything if we get ten new signups
I'll open the phones and we have our
first and it's Laura
Judy neo Laura Godinho has signed up for
a beautifully discounted membership at
www.gfi.com/webmonitor
[Music]
to troll me if you just have a political
question or want to tell me I'm doing a
great job it will all be available if
and when the phone lines open real life
Jolie or Jolie jolly sends an $11 super
chat ah did you not have any money to
sue Anna see an optometrist four years
at a time no my understanding is that
you only need an eye exam every two
years that's why I didn't go for two
years goes on to say because if that's
the case well I do think that I should
buy you a box of contacts at least oh no
I
I have no shortage of contact what I
meant was my prescription changed I have
a new prescription
I went from 2.5 to 3 nearsightedness and
I can just see everything much better
and it's not I've plenty of contacts we
just made the change my optometrist and
I he flipped my eyelids over which was
vile
and he what else did he do took my eye
pressure and slapped me in the face and
then gave me some new contacts and off I
went so I've got plenty of contacts I
deliberately my plan is every two years
I go so everything's fine I appreciate
the concern though Sean dice says did
you hear about the Saudi students in
Oregon helped out of the country by the
royal family before criminal trials we
seem to have a trump royal family in bed
with Saudi Arabia and it's not discussed
Sean yesterday I interviewed Sean Sean
Cavanaugh from The Oregonian about
exactly that and the the video may not
be live on YouTube maybe I don't know
exactly what the publishing schedule is
for that clip but we covered that on the
show yesterday I heard about it we
talked about it with one of the
reporters who has been following it very
closely
Ameen Kendall says Dave I respect and
enjoy watching you however your point of
view on congresswoman Omar's views on
Israeli criticism being anti-semitic was
a bit off still enjoy your show yeah I
never said that her comments were
anti-semitic or Semitic so you may have
you may have misunderstood my position
but I certainly never said that
Stephen Robin says is it true that you
literally asked Sam cedar how to build
his set before you copied it yes I did I
mean the difference is I've set it up
I've come
by our old set which has this screen
behind me with similar paneling
I mean basically what what I copied was
I asked him how did he build the panel's
and he told me and I'm curious did I
said that Sam helped me with what I
needed to buy but did he like if someone
called him and asked him about that I
would be interested in seeing that that
sounds pretty funny let me know if
that's the case let's see here
JH WH good ol says it'll take years if
not decades for the u.s. to gain respect
again even if Trump is gone in 2020 the
world won't forget that it was a large
portion of the American people who
brought him into office I agree and I
recently answered this on audience
questions it might have been last Friday
or maybe it was the Friday before that
the question was how long will it take
for the u.s. to be respected around the
world again after Trump and I said it's
going to take a while and I completely
agree with you
Shawn Geiss which political philosophers
influenced you you know it's hard to say
who influenced me but I've read
everything from you know less political
to more political contem I mean I can't
even a read so much political philosophy
I have a hard time saying who influenced
me I feel like in a sense everybody
influenced me but I think what you're
getting at more is whose views our mind
maybe more modeled after like influenced
in terms of assimilating their views
into mine and I'm not even really sure I
I sort of have a a hot a potpourri I
guess I guess I would say eileen burke
has signed up for a youtube channel
membership that's the second new member
of the evening two types of memberships
count the first is youtube channel
memberships which you can sign up for by
pressing the join button right down
there I may actually let me see if I
even have that now yeah so let's see
here so most YouTube channels don't have
this join button
and of course you probably wouldn't see
analytics and edit video either because
I'm logged in so I guess this is not
even really a good representation but in
any case we're part of a beta program
with YouTube where this join button
appears and okay and I guess because I'm
logged in as our own channel I can't do
that but if you press the join button
you will be taken to a page where you
can become a YouTube channel member that
counts towards our target of 10 new
members today also I prefer this because
we keep much more of the money you can
go to WWE at Macomb and sign up for a
YouTube or for a website membership our
newest member is Clinton Waltman who
just signed up that is number 3 okay so
if we get 10 new members this evening
I'll open up the phone lines at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 we are at 3 out of 10 actually
no we're at 4 out of 10 because Jeremy
Sutton has now signed up as well Jeremy
thank you for signing up we are at 4 out
of 10 I don't have to take phone calls
but if people want me to take phone
calls I gladly will and coupon codes
this is 20 20 and save 35 are available
the phone number if and when we open it
will be 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 a lot of
questions and Commons on people's minds
Augustine says David I've recently
uncovered euro uncovered your videos on
expert village and now please explain
yourself yeah this is this is funny
so there are videos on a YouTube of me
doing everything from training dogs
which I actually don't really know
anything about I know nothing about I
have no credentials for training dogs
under a pseudonym to teaching drums
which I actually did teach drums for a
while so that I have I have a little bit
more authority and I guess you would say
and the way I and it's actually former
producer Louis that's to blame I'll tell
the story years ago producer Louis when
we were both just working part time for
the show when the show was not what it
is today
we both had other things that we did I
did video production and marketing work
and Lewis at one point was contracted by
a documentary production company that
had a contract with a howl and expert
village to produce instructional videos
so Lewis came to me and he said hey I'm
working as a camera person for this
production house we have a deal with E
how an expert village do you want to
teach some video do you want to teach
some stuff so we started with I was like
21 years old we started with me teaching
drums which I actually know something
about and then we said hey we should
just like look up on the internet some
information about stuff and then you can
teach it and we did some where I'm
teaching dog training which is insane I
literally just looked up on the internet
how to train a dog and then we did
videos never should have been hired to
do it never should have went should have
been published now we can all laugh
about it because everybody's been paid
and who cares if the videos get removed
from YouTube but yes there are videos of
me teaching all sorts of different
things and please don't look them up
please don't look them up because it's
embarrassing
Sasquatch hunter says second-choice
runoff voting only way forward I am a
big advocate of runoff voting there are
some problems with it
most of whoa sorry about that completely
flipped my mic in the other direction
that's never happened before
there are some problems with it most of
which we've addressed but we have an
expert on this issue coming up on the
program maybe as soon as next week if
not the week after and we're gonna deal
with that
further Shauna has become a youtube
channel member she is member new member
number five of the evening
Julie Peterson has become a youtube
channel member she is new member number
six of the evening and when we get to
ten I will open up the phone lines real
life Jolie says uh-oh if that's actually
the case well my viewpoint may be a
little bit off given that I personally
see the optometrist every six month haha
yeah my insurance doesn't cover twice a
year visits to the optometrist it's
every two years and
you you must have good insurance and if
that's the case congratulations I gotta
love it okay a few other new members
that I want to say hello to on our path
to ten new members to open up the phone
lines
Peter wicks is a new david pakman show
member on our website that is new member
number seven and Dina Lindh or Lindy
probably Lindh is new member number
eight of the evening okay so we have a
phone line that phone line is six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
I make an offer to you which is if you
would like me to take some phone calls
and hear from folks as I mentioned this
is going to be the last live stream for
a little bit because I've got to go down
to Washington DC for some meetings and
that this is probably the last
livestream of the week people want to
chime in on the news ask questions make
comments on the phones I'm glad to do it
but we're looking for ten new members
membership is not expensive it's the
number one funding source for what we do
we give the show away in fact we produce
the show at our cost for 200 community
radio and television stations and part
of the reason why we're able to do that
is because of membership support so the
normal rates I think are very reasonable
six dollars a month and sixty for the
year but we have two coupons codes
available this is 20 20 will save you
40% off of any membership save 35 will
save you $35 specifically off of the $60
per year membership I see people in the
chat saying David save 35 is not working
it's working fine people are using it
but it will only work on the $60 per
year membership and we're we're getting
close to more new members and I'll open
up the phone lines shoshone the elegant
white tiger king is asking for my
thoughts on the yang gang mirroring 2016
trump support I don't even know what
that's about to be honest I saw a couple
of posts on our subreddit from people
saying hey it looks like alright Trump
supporters are shifting to Andrew yang
is he like a secret libertarian in some
way or
what's going on I I'm not sure about
that I like Andrew yang a lot but I can
understand how some of his ideas would
appeal to both left and right wing
libertarians although he's really more
of a left-wing libertarian but I've not
really seen too much evidence suggesting
that this alt-right Trump shift to yang
is happening I'm not denying that it's
happening I'm just saying I've not seen
that evidence but I'm gonna research it
further a mecca 101 says Eric Prince is
going back to testify in front of
Congress regarding his lies about
meetings exposed on an Al Jazeera
interview stunning Eric Prince
absolutely crushed in an Al Jazeera
interview where he ended up he I'm
trying to summarize it he said he was
asked about a meeting that took place at
Trump Tower which he didn't disclose
when he testified before Congress and he
ended up having really no explanation
other than I lied but that's not what he
the explanation he gave the explanation
he ultimately gave was that the
transcript of the testimony might be
wrong which is I mean just laughably
ridiculous and I've not heard that this
is the first I'm hearing from mecca 101
that he is being pulled back in to
testify before Congress I'm glad that he
is he should be and I'm looking forward
to that okay since I have just a bit of
a lull in the super chats
let me now play for you I think you're
going to like this many of you know that
people from the Westboro Baptist Church
known for their God hates [ __ ] slogan
which is horrible this is not
terminology I use but this is what they
are known for they have sort of been out
of the public picture for a while and I
think that that's a good thing and I
haven't interviewed anyone from the
Westboro Baptist Church for a long time
but David Pakman show producer Noah
Ferguson told me that they were going to
be protesting at the Virginia State
Capitol because of Danika Rome the first
transgender individual elected to the
any US Statehouse state legislature they
were going to be protesting at Noah's
alma mater of Virginia Commonwealth
University and so he went down there
and there's this hilarious video we
played this on the show today but it's
not publishing for a while so I'll show
it to you here I think you'll like this
this is Noah trying to talk to Shirley
phelps-roper she has this boombox going
you see it down here by this police
officers foot she's surrounded by police
and ignoring all media requests until
Noah says he's from the David Pakman
show
she immediately turns down the boombox
and talks to him so let's take a listen
to this it might take me a moment to set
the audio correctly and just as a
reminder I'm planning to open the phone
lines if we get two more new members on
our web site waiting on two more new
members and if we get them I will open
up the phone lines check this out this
was the exchange between our producer
and a very tightly protected as you can
see police all over Shirley phelps-roper
from the Westboro Baptist Church that's
really that's really interesting I love
that that's really interesting
I mean it's so obviously insincere but
it's it's just an attempt to placate
Shirley and then Noah continues with his
questions you still think David Pakman
is going to hell is everyone in David
patents are Tian's going to help
transgenders and elevated it again with
lightning speed to a position of respect
what God has called an abomination and
you said you would be willing to come
back on our show what what do you think
you guys would want to talk about if you
came back on so there's a moment here
where I actually am unsure Noah asks if
everyone in the audience is going to
hell and she brings up a transgender
people and I can't tell whether she is
saying everyone in our audience is trans
or that our audience has elevated trans
people in some way I want to just go
back and listen to that piece one more
time let me back it up that's gender
yeah second listen it actually doesn't
sound like she's saying the entire
audience is transgender it sounds like
she's saying the entire audience
considers trans people to be people and
in and in her mind that has elevated
them to some kind of status that she
thinks they doesn't just they don't
deserve or something like that very very
weird but in any case there is there is
Shirley phelps-roper and yeah I don't
think there's any interest in actually
having her back on the show but in any
case nice job I know Ferguson they're
getting a comment from her I love it
okay let's see a few more super chats
here Horror V says with two R's thoughts
on exiling criminals working against us
exiling criminals working against the US
I don't know what that means I'm having
trouble parsing that grammatically
exiling criminals who are working
against the u.s. exiling them to where I
just don't think I actually understand
um real-life Jolie says oh that's a
funny story I'm actually on Medicare
okay maybe medicare covers optometry
appointments every six months me cope is
Paula says Joe Rogan called black people
apes you still go his PC
you still go his PC Oh podcast yeah you
know when I saw that clip of Joe Rogan
talking about Apes and black people I
thought that he was ridiculing racists
doubt that's my recollection although I
haven't seen that for a very long time
maybe my recollection is wrong Lance
Smith says what are your thoughts on the
Sam cedar charlie Kirk debate a
political on 2018 if you happen to catch
it you know I saw five minutes of it um
that when it happened I was flying home
and then I just never have time to watch
anything so I only saw five minutes and
I saw the five minutes I saw it seemed
like Sam was just making very sober
arguments against the nonsense Charlie
Kirk was saying and it didn't really
seem like Charlie Kirk had many strong
arguments so I mean I don't know I guess
I'm biased but I wasn't hugely
influenced in Charlie Kirk's direction
from what I saw but that's based on five
minutes it might have been a half hour
or an hour or even an hour and a half
long so I'm not not totally sure but
maybe I'll go back and watch it if I
have some time let me say thank you to
Gwendolyn Anderson Gwendolyn Anderson
has signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership and she is the ninth new
member of the evening if we get to 10
new members I will open up the phone
lines now I will tell you I don't have
unlimited time to stream this evening
because it's a very very busy week and
so if people want me to open up the
phone lines I would suggest that we just
get one more person to sign up for
membership at WWE and pac-man calm it's
not expensive you can use the coupon
code this is 2022 save 40% you can use
the coupon code save 35 to discount
specifically the $60 membership to just
$25 which I have to tell you is a damn
good deal that's like two dollars in
eight cents a month for hours and hours
and hours of programming that we produce
but if people don't want the phone lines
open I don't have to open them up but if
we do get one more member I'll open them
up and and take some phone calls and I
would love to hear from some of the
folks who are watching today Brian
Walters with the
hi super chat of the evening $30 I don't
know if you've already said who your top
three running for president is do you
mind saying who they are
thank you David yeah they are in no
particular order
Andrew yang Bernie Sanders Elizabeth
Warren or to say it a different way
Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren Andrew
yang or to say it a different way
Elizabeth Warren Andrew yang Bernie
Sanders the point is in no particular
order I'm just naming them maybe an
order of of presidential announcements
or something like that those are my top
three right now I see Andrew yang has
just sort of very qualified officially
for the first debate at least which will
be super interesting Bernie Sanders is
leading among
declared candidates Joe Biden still
leading Bernie in most polls and then
Elizabeth Warren stuck right around 9%
in the latest Iowa poll that I saw and
we will see whether she's able to make
more headway there it's very early still
a long time but those are my top three
yang Warren and Bernie Sanders Doug
Condor says hey mr. P please define
trolling I don't know how I would this
is sort of like when Jesse Lee Peterson
asked me to describe a man let me see if
I can find let's see how wikipedia
defines it just to start an internet
slang a troll is a person who starts
quarrels or upsets people on the
Internet to distract and sow discord by
posting inflammatory and digressive
extraneous or off-topic messages in an
online community such as a news group
forum chatroom or blog let me zoom this
out a little now it's getting kind of
small with the intent of provoking
readers into displaying emotional
responses and normalizing tangential
discussion basically trolling is posting
on the Internet in bad faith isn't that
a way that would be somewhat reasonable
to sum up if you are posting it's not
the subject matter that determines
whether someone is trolling it's not
even necessarily the vocabulary that
determines
what whether someone is trolling um I
think it's just bad faith you're not
really looking to have a discussion you
are looking to inflame you are looking
to distract you're looking to sow
discord I think that's how I would
define it and if you're upset that I'm
looking on Wikipedia rather than
defining it myself I kind of do
political analysis not dictionary
definitions as I told a Jesse Lee
Peterson so that that I think is though
is a perfectly reasonable assessment
Jeremy Sutton sends a $19.99 pound super
chat what about the super right-wing
radio TV talk show host that said all
real mens were conservative he asked you
about transgender what was his name was
he impaired that's actually who I was
just talking about that was Jesse Lee
Peterson and let's see if I can pull up
a little bit of the most recent
interview I did with him there I've
mentioned this before and I'll mention
it again there is there is discussion
there is a rumbling of doing another
in-person event with Jesse Lee Peterson
in front of an actual audience last time
I did it at his Christian men's
counseling center in Los Angeles
California and it was absolutely bonkers
let me see if I can find the video and
just pull it up a little bit for you
here it is you'll notice let me see if I
can get this all properly set up you'll
notice that at the very beginning we're
just kind of sitting there and just
talking casually oh wait this isn't the
very beginning we're just sitting there
oh this is me introducing it let's see
if I can get to the right spot yeah
before the title comes up this is so
funny check this out
[Laughter]
yeah
so what was going on there was that we
were like 20 minutes late or something
or 10 minutes late starting because he
was having some kind of tech Fiasco in
the back room he was he was starting to
get agitated and complain about how
nothing was working correctly and blah
blah blah and I guess the idea was that
we would start with this this entire
entire title card thing and then it
would cut to us but somehow we ended up
on the stream and fortunately nothing
weird was going on amazing
welcome to to the father State YouTube
live I'm Justin Lee Peterson apologize
for the late straw but we are black
everybody people are late right so that
was basically that that's the gist of
everything that went on and obviously I
don't take it seriously but we're we are
planning a live Jesse Lee Peterson thing
I don't even know if he knows about it
yet but I'm planning it with my team and
the venue we have a venue in mind we
have a timeline in mind but it would be
inappropriate for me to comment on it
particularly before anyone has even
talked to Jesse Lee Peterson about it
okay I've got a few other things to
discuss I will remind you I we we are
potentially opening the phone lines
tonight at six one seven eight three
zero forty seven fifty we're waiting for
our tenth new member were stuck at nine
the target was ten new members at WWJ
pakman.com and we are stuck at nine the
last new member was Gwendolyn Anderson
and we don't want Grendel and Anderson's
membership to be moot and to be stuck at
nine so we're ready to open the phone
lines I have the phone queue system
ready to go we just need one new member
a WWN pokémon comm to coupon codes
available
this is 20/20 or saved 35 you can read
about those in the video description
luca Selland says hypothetical Bernie
wins the primary who will he choose his
running mate who would you choose to be
his running mate
I don't know and I don't know I I can
tell you that I've had a handful of
people tweet to me David will you
endorse bernie + Tulsi and the answer is
no Tulsi is not for me okay with peace
and love to everybody in the audience
and everybody who likes Tulsi etc Tulsi
is not for me
so if Bernie were to win the primary I
would be interested in seeing a Bernie
Bernie Andrew yang Bernie Elizabeth
Warren I mean there's electability
issues with with all of these pairings I
would be interested in seeing Bernie who
else would I be interested you know I've
just I I really take these things one
step at a time and before the 2018
midterms people would call in or send
super chat saying who are you supporting
or who do you think is likely to win the
2020 Democratic primary and I would say
we've got a midterm election to try to
win here I don't think we should even be
thinking about that until we get past it
and in the same way I we don't even know
we might be about to get two more
candidates in beto or org and Joe Biden
so I am just not ready at all to start
talking about by vice presidential
candidates yet investigate 311 sends a
$10 super chat I don't know what that I
don't know if that's a thing if that's
some kind of meme investigate 311 which
was yesterday right March 11th Senate is
voting to get the u.s. out of Yemen
tomorrow including ending the naval
blockade and sharing military
intelligence with Saudi Arabia please
cover this coverage of Yemen has been
horrible from everyone okay let me make
a note of that
just so I can check it out tomorrow for
the show always appreciate suggestions
from the audience and I will check that
out yeah the thing I actually I just met
a very interesting guy the other day a
Yemeni Jew and you might say there's
like no Jews actually left I think
there's actually like a couple dozen
Jews left in Yemen and I think they
might be living at us under under
protection somewhere because it's so
dangerous for them he
family left Yemen some time ago and he
had some very very interesting stories
that maybe someday maybe someday he
would be able to share on the program
Arielle Fernandez who you might see has
a logo here called the David Pakman show
flag because he is a YouTube channel
member that is very cool do you believe
the United States of America will ever
become a dominant party system with the
Democratic Party being that political
party no I think it's more likely
Arielle that site let me see if I can
say this the right way if at some point
political winds are such or the
electoral system changes such that what
today is the Democratic Party becomes
dominant in American politics I think
that that downfall of the Republican
Party will coincide with the Democratic
Party splitting and you will still end
up with the minimum a duopoly I think
that that's how the system is designed
that is how a lot of structures within
our system are set up so I believe that
if the Democratic Party gets too
powerful relative to the Republican
Party where Democrats are winning all
the time and Republicans are not I think
you will see the Democratic Party split
and sort of become the new duopoly or
maybe it'll even be a three-way with the
Republican Party okay new member
pamela Weller Pamela Weller took a while
today but we did it we got to ten new
members so I will open up the phone
lines at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 if you want
to talk to me call in at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 I will just wait a moment or two for
people to get connected and then I will
take some phone calls
please don't troll me but if you have
disagreements by all means call that is
that is more than welcome
Jeremy Sutton says sounds like a gay
conversion therapy session with Jesse
Lee Peterson seriously though the guy
seems high or very very blow Vaughn the
bottom end of the spectrum how could he
even be racist he blamed blacks
yeah he's a very very strange guy Rory
drew
hi David hypothetically how differently
do you think Trump would
operate were the us to have a system
identical to the UK's parliamentary
system you know I would hope that in
having to actually get up in front of
the equivalent of Parliament if we had
it here I would hope that his clear lack
of capacity lack of cognitive ability to
be President of the United States would
have been sown deny ibly exposed that he
would no longer be president by now that
that's my hope and that's probably
unrealistic given the devotion of the
Republican Party to the cult of
personality that is Donald Trump okay I
think I am ready to take some phone
calls here let's see I've got to make
sure everything is all properly set up I
don't want to accidentally flash
anyone's phone numbers up on the screen
which I accidentally did a little while
back okay um all right let's see here
let's start with our caller one more
time the number six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty let's start
with our caller from the 72 zero area
code caller from seven to zero
introduce yourself what's your name
where you calling from that is you yeah
hey David my name is Jordan I won't
calling from Kansas hey Jordan what's
going on so I was wondering if you heard
about I think it's bill weld planning to
primary Donald Trump yes I did
I was wondering a few things that had
any significance or effects like you
know I would love to believe that it
does bill weld is an interesting guy he
ran correct me if I'm wrong Jordan but I
think he ran as Gary Johnson's
libertarian vice president in 2016 right
I think so yeah yeah he's an interesting
guy you know among Republicans he's he's
much more reasonable than I mean you
know if you give me bill weld or Ted
Cruz obviously I choose bill weld he was
governor here in Massachusetts years ago
I think he has no shot to be quite
honest I find it interesting and any
damage he can do to Trump I'm all for I
just find it hard to imagine he's going
to get much traction I think Kasich has
a much better shot at getting some
traction
um and I can ask one more yes sir
I was wondering what you think would be
the most important issue that a
Democratic winner would be in 2020
well I it's hard to pick one but the
systemic the major systemic issues that
I want to see dealt with in our
political system are campaign finance
and money in politics number one number
two climate changes a meta issue that
has to be dealt with number three the
net neutrality Sat slash media
consolidation because we learn about
most issues through media and the
Internet so that's another meta issue
that simply has to be dealt with and
number four changing the voting system
we have to better allow third parties to
participate those are like my four meta
issues that I want whoever is the
nominee to be tackling okay cool thanks
for taking my call
all right appreciate the call thank you
very much we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 let's go to our caller from
the 8 5 8 area code who's calling from 8
5 8 go this is come off from San Diego
hey Tomas what's going on yeah what your
thoughts are on Republican strategies
like calling the Democratic Party the
Democrat Party like I just I have lived
with a regulator so I just hear it all
the time so it's kind of weird so I the
one I heard
so you're saying first of all calling
never saying the Democratic Party always
saying the Democrat Party the other one
is demon rats right that's another one
oh really
yeah that one's just stupid listen
here's the thing I mean okay so for
years now they never say the Democratic
Party because if they say the Democratic
Party even if they're saying it as in
like capital D Democratic they don't
want to concede that it sounds like
they're saying small D Democratic like
the party of democracy so they say the
Democrat Party in to some degree it's
probably effective I find it really
childish and stupid but it probably has
some effect that is beneficial to
Republicans sadly yeah whenever I hear
something say that I just label my hack
and and move on I like
so so you did you say you live with
right-wingers um I live I live in a
pretty conservative area oh it's not
like you have right-wing Georgia but
like yeah but you don't have right-wing
roommates you're saying oh no no okay
all right good yeah I would have been
worried about you if you did that would
have been tough yeah I couldn't do that
okay yeah all right thanks for the
coffee she ate it six one seven eight
three zero 47 50 let's go to the 502
area code who's calling from 502 today
my name is Matt hey Matt what's going on
hey big fan to show my question is
regards the injury gang in in regards
his position on ubi yes I've done a lot
of research on his website and the one
thing I'm concerned about and it's
something you mentioned before in a
previous video is how Evi would be used
i noticed that he's mentioned before
that you could opt in out of welfare and
replace the vbi but how would you think
that would apply to something like
Social Security
I think it's it's problematic and we're
trying to get Andrew back on you know
we've been covering Andrews campaign for
a long time now we were interviewing him
long before he was on Joe Rogan or WBUR
or any of that he's been on all sorts of
stuff The Breakfast Club and we're
trying to get him back on the program
because I have some disagreements with
him and I as I said he's one of my top
three candidates but I have I don't
think that that's a good idea I'm
concerned about it I think that his view
on tuition free college is is just wrong
I want to talk to him about that I think
tuition free college is both a good idea
and economically stimulative so yeah I
mean I think that ubi ubi can't be
number one used to subsidize employers
who want to continue paying employees
like crap number I don't want to see
that that can't be the point of ubi and
I also don't want to see the opt-in
opt-out stuff if you want to say we're
getting rid of food stamps and you know
if you want to kind of come up with a
whole list of programs and you say
here's the total of what someone might
get from all of these programs we're
going to get rid of them all
as well as all of the bureaucracy that
comes with them we're gonna save a ton
of money and we will just cut a
universal basic income cheque to people
I'm open to hearing that but to start
talking about opt in opt out replacing
Social Security or anything like that
that's that's the wrong approach in my
mind yeah I would agree with that
because I like you I think that it is
something that's probably unavoidable
that will have to go down that path but
I think to kind of replace our existing
system I think that that's kind of the
intellectual dishonesty there a lot of
conservatives like libertarians seem to
be on board with it because they don't
like these other programs they just want
to just replace it with something simple
but I just think that would be a
fundamentally bad idea I think it would
be and the the thing about ubi is that
there are so many proposals for how it
would be implemented what the amounts of
money would be etc that ubi doesn't mean
just one thing in the same way that I
don't know welfare as many things
welfare isn't one thing ubi is not
necessarily just one thing but I
completely agree with your take on it
okay yeah and that's but I was wondering
if that if that was something you had a
concern and I certainly hope that if you
have him back on the show that would be
a question would ask him oh I will I
absolutely will thanks for the call I
appreciate it all right thank you okay
see you later let's see six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty let's
go to our caller from the 972 area code
who's there from 972 today hi this is
Tanner in Dallas and I have been looking
to discuss a part of our elections that
doesn't on how to improve them that
doesn't get a lot of talk and that is
how long they're getting and I was
wondering what you think could be done
to help shorten the election cycles make
them more comprised in in in limiting
the amount of time in political office
candidates could campaign for yeah
that's got to be a package of election
reform right so we need an election
reform package that includes campaign
finance reform and we just go to public
funding for elections we get the super
PAC money out we get individual
donations in the way that they have we
got to get all of that stuff out
in addition to that we've got a limb at
the time I think that six months is very
reasonable I think six months is
extraordinarily reasonable maybe eight
months or something like that six to
eight months is what I was thinking as
well but it's not just presidential
candidates but it's kind of it's going
in to all levels for example here in
Dallas we're going to be electing a new
mayor later this year in the elect that
elections not till November and we've
had some candidates campaign as long as
September October of last year if you're
just getting infuriated there's this
some idea in behavioral economics and
decision-making theory which is that
information has a diminishing utility
okay and the the example that's often
used Tanner is if you imagine that
you're buying a car right you have no
information about cars at all so what do
you do well first you inform yourself
about the types of cars that there are
there's trucks there's SUVs there's
compact cars whatever you now are going
to be much better able to make a really
important decision about the type of car
you're looking for
you then need to look into what a cars
cost what brands are their safety
ratings etc and you're really going to
be able to make a better decision on the
basis of that information at a certain
point if you've been researching for ten
months and you're getting down to the
minutiae of what brands sparkplugs come
Factory four different vehicles or
whatever the additional information and
the time it takes you to acquire that
information has a smaller and smaller
additional value to you until a point at
which it actually has a negative value
potentially because you're just missing
out on actually getting a car and
getting use out of the car I think it's
a perfect analogy to this election stuff
we don't actually need 19 months to
figure out who we're going to vote for
or 11 months until the primary or
whatever we can get all the information
we need in a far shorter amount of time
period absolutely I would maybe put that
to buying a house or an apartment
absolutely absolutely
all right it's the classic economic
example is candy bars like if you get
one candy bar it's got quite a bit of
value and if you get a second candy bar
you could eat
candy bars but that second one it's no
longer as unique at a certain point if
you keep eating candy bars they start
having a negative value you're gonna get
yourself sick and I think it's a good
analogy all right well thank you very
much
okay thanks appreciate the call yeah
thanks for calling in um let me get to a
couple of super chats before I get back
to the phones let's see here
Joshua Carr says what potential Democrat
winning policies do you think are not
getting enough traction in the party
well net neutrality is so important and
the the American public is basically
with Democrats on it but it is unclear
whether it's an effective issue in terms
of voting because it's very sort of
seasonal in terms of when there's about
to be some thing you start getting the
FCC comments and big websites like
Reddit and others start activating
around it and politicians who say they
will defend Internet freedom get a lot
of traction but then when it's not
acutely in the works when it's just like
hey we've got to restore net neutrality
it's so important and it it really
should be a winning issue for Democrats
I just don't know if it actually would
get them electoral traction I'd have to
think about which one would be effective
I mean I think we've learned that gun
related stuff is not effective Joshua
but I'll think about that a little more
Arielle Fernandez says I was thinking
the Democratic Party will split into two
different political parties in that
scenario one being socially liberal and
economically left-wing and the other
also being socially liberal but
economically centrist you know the
current Democratic Party is sort of
socially liberal and economically
centrist and so that and so you might
have Democrats and Social Democrats I
don't know but yeah I think I think you
and I are basically on the same page
Arielle let's see who else wants to
chime in on the phones how about the
eight four five area code caller from
eight four five what's your name where
are you calling from okay so I'm hearing
myself on like a five second
I was this my name is hayleen what's
going on and if you're listening to the
stream in the background
please please please can you know yeah
that's crazy I know hi so my question is
what are your thoughts regarding student
loan forgiveness
especially after today's crazy news yeah
so today a bunch of celebrities and
others have been pulled into I don't
even know how to describe it a lien is
basically they were caught bribing tests
like test taking system test taking
companies to get their kids better
scores so that they would get into good
schools is that roughly what it is it's
so unbelievably tragic and so what do
you think about student loan forgiveness
for the kids who really had to take out
loans who really did get into college
and now they're up to their eyeballs and
debt yep so I think a couple things
number one the loan forgiveness programs
that we have have to be expanded that
that that's just absolutely clear bigger
picture if we so obviously if someone is
determined to have been the target of
predatory student lending absolutely
loan forgiveness current programs need
to be expanded where I think it starts
to get complex is that a lot of the
problem isn't so much that people are
going into debt or to go to college or
that the loans themselves are predatory
but that there is a feedback loop of
loans being easier and easier to get and
College getting more and more expensive
in a way that's completely out of line
with wages so I just don't know a lien
if we're giving the loans I'm open to
forgiving the loans depending on who it
is that's paying for it so to speak but
there's like a much bigger issue with
the cost of college that goes beyond the
debt piece yes it's a big conversation I
know this is like a small question for a
it's a big thing
that we can't educate our children yeah
but something at some point like the
system is not sustainable college costs
can't keep increasing at the rate that
they are with people taking out bigger
and bigger loans for careers that simply
are not going to empower them to ever
pay those loans off some things go crash
you know
hello trade schools you know well yeah I
mean trade school that's that's a whole
other can of worms and I think that
that's interesting and it's the right
choice for a lot of people but at the
same time we don't want to be
disincentivizing careers that may not
earn a lot of money but are still
valuable careers in other ways and
that's the concern with just saying
trade school you know yeah it's so
complicated I mean we want a liberal a
liberal arts education is very important
that's right and really a conservative
able to read you need to be able to
write you need to be able to read
literature and and think and think you
need to learn how to think and so it's
expensive to be able to do that it
shouldn't be well conservatives have
made it very popular to sort of pretend
that liberal arts education czar just
liberal indoctrination and the fact that
the word liberal is in there has been
useful to them but it's it's just so
important yeah
hey we thank you for the call all right
fight take care uh Neil Morton has a
super chat where he says joined a couple
of days ago and sent this extra just to
get my name mentioned just kidding
wanted to say I like your rhetorical
style keep it up thanks Neil you know
your name would have been mentioned
eventually in the new member
announcements a little peek behind the
curtain we are like three years behind
on new member announcements this is a
really good problem to have if you're a
show that depends on member support but
right now we are I think it's like two
and a half years backed up on announcing
new members on the show so glad to
mention you today Neil appreciate your
support let's go to our caller from the
nine seven zero area area code he's
calling from nine seven zero today hi
David
this is Alexa from Colorado hey Alexis
what's going on
um Mattawa I had a
I'd watched I was kind of curious on
your opinion on the importance of
transgender rights and little
acknowledgement in the Democratic Party
I watched Bernie Sanders recently and he
very clearly said gay and straight man
and woman almost it was discrediting or
I don't know what's your opinion on the
importance of stuff such as that in the
Democratic Party well he didn't mention
bisexual either I guess according to
what you're saying right that's true I
mean I guess there's a couple of
interpretations one is we can make a
really micro analysis of the language
and say because he didn't mention
bisexual or transgender he doesn't care
or doesn't think that bi and trans
people are worthy of supporter
acknowledgement in some way the other
would be when he says gay and lesbian
he's using it as shorthand for LGBT
which does include all of those things
and maybe we should pay more attention
to what he was advocating rather than
making a sort of linguistic analysis I
don't know I didn't see it I'll be
honest of course of course and I agree
with that and it's a gay and straight
gay and lesbian but I'm sorry dates
right oh yeah why do you think it's a
bit of a talking point at the moment
especially with how much the Republican
Party is attacking transgender people
taking away privileges I feel like that
would be something he would have brought
up Hettie supported that yeah but so do
we have reason to think Bernie Sanders
does not support transgender rights I
cannot find anything about it
yeah no I can't I have no reason to
think that either and given his record
of decades and being on the forefront of
gay and lesbian rights decades ago I
would I would default to the position
that this is something Bernie of finds
important and supports barring evidence
to the contrary that's that's what I
would take as a position okay yeah and I
really really want to say that way too
and then after hearing this stuff though
I'm just I'm kind of on the edge about
it I really want to think he is but I'm
wondering how important it is for you or
Democratic candidate to be for those
rights Oh
I mean it's listen listen I it's hard
for me to imagine I would not support
any candidate I it's I'm sort of like
having a hard time even putting it into
words we're at this point you know that
if a Democratic candidate says I don't
think
that we need to include LGBT status in
non-discrimination ordinances or
something like that I mean it's just a
non-starter it's almost inconceivable to
me maybe there are some candidates that
are not getting a lot of attention whose
records I've not looked at closely
enough who who are sort of indifferent
to that but it's hard for me to imagine
that it's a given that it's a it's of
upmost importance including you know
positions on health care and so many
other things that should just be a given
it yeah of course of course is almost
any question all right well thank you
very much okay thank you for the call
really appreciate it
razzamatazz has sent a super chat saying
I tried to use the coupon code save
thirty five but it was invalid oh boy I
addressed this razzamatazz here's the
thing the coupon code save thirty five
only works on the $60 a year membership
okay if you apply that code to any other
membership it will not work so when you
go to WWE at muncom you have to switch
from monthly to yearly and then make
sure sixty dollars a year is selected
and hit sign up then it will work and
people are using it people have been
using it all night it will only work on
that membership in particular trust me
though it works elias that actress sends
a link to some kind of oh it's it's a
link to the story about the actresses
and ceos arrested in the call nationwide
college scandal yeah we'll be talking
about that on the show tomorrow it's an
insane story and Arielle Fernandez is
back saying thank you for answering my
question
yeah I don't know why sometimes Arielle
has the little david pakman show flag
and sometimes not I'm not not really
super sure about that okay let me take
another phone call why don't we go to
the seven one six area code who's
calling from seven one six today
hi baby Toria for Canada whoa okay did
you say Jordan from Canada yeah we're
from the states what I'm living in
Canada right now
okay good maybe just keep a little more
space between your mouth and the phone
because you're coming through very
over-over driven okay I'm sorry
oh that's much better thank you okay um
I had an on
no question okay uh when I was about 18
I had a neighbor Dallas from Argentina
yep and they gave me a whole bunch of
books like stuff by jorge luis borges oh
your quarters are right a few other
writers I was wondering what your
opinion on pinion was of that type of
literature
it's a mantastic I mean it's absolutely
fantastic gorgeous has some of the
bamming both boris and cordosa have some
of the best short story literature that
I've ever read
Gordana has a novel called I think in
English it's translated as hopscotch
which yeah yeah exactly
which I read part of years ago and it
was like a little bit you know I read
Spanish but it was it was a little tough
for me based on my reading level at the
time I should I should resume it but
this these this is top notch literature
and yeah I would recommend it to anybody
in the audience okay it's a little bit
easier in English like I was able to
finish it yeah I figured that you had it
in in English not in Spanish yeah okay
good well excellent
okay we're glad you're eating it
appreciate the phone call okay I'm gonna
have to cut the stream there I've got a
run got a bunch of stuff to plan
including tomorrow's program and this
upcoming trip to Washington DC apologies
to everybody who called in that I didn't
get to I will take calls again I will
stream again really appreciate your
joining me